on the streets of yemen's capital sana
there's both hope and skepticism the
two-month extension of a um brokered
truce comes as a relief but many say the
benefits of the agreement have yet to
reach most people across the country
extending the truth should lead to peace
but we're still waiting for salaries to
be paid and for the integration of the
central bank and national currency
people are suffering a truce like the
previous one is in a way useless because
there's no war but there's also no peace
with the extension the focus now turns
to expanding the terms of the troops
infrastructure has been completely
destroyed both civilian and military
there's nothing left so in a settlement
the people of yemen have the right to
benefit from it starting from
humanitarian aid health and education
everything has been affected
this medical center is a painful
reminder of the conflict and its victims
for months the truce has led to less
attacks and less fighting but for many
the damage was done years ago
fighting between the saudi-led coalition
and houthi fighters have scarred the
country and its people
we want the truce to remove this dark
period from our lives for the siege to
be over for salaries to be paid we want
peace
promises of ceasefires have repeatedly
been broken in yemen there's hope
repeated truth extensions will bring
them closer to a permanent peace deal
al jazeera